welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 2
the passenger a big group of an episode
both in terms of its giant spiders
and what we all kept shouting at baby
yoda's binge eating there are actually a
lot of overlooked details this episode
including a new threat to mando and baby
oda that i think we're all missing
and the real reason i think baby oda
might be eating those eggs let's find
all the easter eggs this episode and
chow down
and uh yeah i am wearing our custom this
is the way
shirt which you can buy from our merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com and for a
bit more you can write in your own
custom shout out that we will feature in
the next episode of wikileaks there's a
lot of great options in our store
including hoodies and a hi i'm eric voss
shirt
why not new rockstarsmerch.com okay
spoiler warning here we go
we opened back on tatooine and you might
have noticed a wider aspect ratio this
season it's a more cinematic angle
showing off the western inspired
landscape imagery and i appreciate how
the classic
lens flare trope is compounded to
account for both of tattooing sons
the bandits who snare mando are led by a
nekto
the nekto cartel overtook tatooine's
crime operation after jabba's syndicate
fell
the one who holds baby yoda at knife
point is the same race as the jerk who
snapped at rey on jakku in the force
awakens
and when mando's speeder bite gets
tripped up i like the detail of him
igniting his jet
pack just briefly to control his landing
physics usually don't matter in the star
wars universe
but when they're applied to stunt work
like this they make each blow and fall
feel more authentic and the fact that a
nikdo led this trap makes me wonder
whether this was an isolated incident or
organized plan thought out you guys
noticed their target
yeah these guys were following mando in
the child or were
told where to find them and the editing
includes an insert of the final guide
looking at boba fett's helmet but
not taking it that could mean boba who
did spot them last episode could have
alerted this gang or it's possible that
they were tipped off by
pelimoto who knew mando's destination
was interested in baby yoda and hasn't
seemed entirely honest with mando for
all we know she could have rigged that
game of sabach with dr mandible just to
squeeze more money out of mando to cover
that bet
just a little conspiracy we're gonna
need to keep our eye on in the mos
eisley cantina mando passes the k-99
bartender droid again
like the k-99 from jabba's palace and
this one's voiced by mark hamill last
season unfortunately
the bounty killed no longer operates
from tatooine
dr mandible is a killik race native to
alderaan
payton reid directed this episode he
directed the marvel ant-man movies so
this could be a tip of the hat to his
own work but if you watch closely in
episode 5 last season both dr mandible
and this frog woman
were visible in the cantina in the
background so it's pretty cool for the
show to reveal more of a narrative for
these background characters
oh but before we continue we want to
thank bessie for sponsoring this video
these shoes are great even if you're a
rough and tough space bounty hunter the
last thing you want to worry about is
stepping in a puddle and getting your
socks soaked looking for you mando
bessie makes knit sneakers that are 100
waterproof and weatherproof these bad
boys are breathable
letting the air out without letting
water in
so things stay nice and fresh unlike
some big old clunky boots sure spurs
sound cool but they must be really
impractical while driving
bessie shoes are super stretchy they fit
like a sock they only weigh 175 grams
they're also made with this space-age
dynamex material so these are a real
everyday shoe no matter the weather
they're also sustainably made and super
easy to clean
if you're going on hikes or running
errands or playing some keep away with
your kid brothers baby yoda doll during
those wintry months
besties shoes will keep you comfortable
protected and looking great i'm too
afraid to kill bugs by
crushing it so i'm just gonna spray them
with water
no no i got my shoe all wet but
my feet are dry these are more
investigase
thanks bessie you
they have an incredible early black
friday offer going right now
so go grab yourself a pair for the rainy
season while they still have sizes and
you can thank me later check them out in
the link below and if you missed a black
friday sale no worries you can still use
my code
new rockstars to get 25 off your
bessie's shoes
and thanks again to best seat for
sponsoring this pelo moto winsebach with
this hand
idiot's array is the same hand lando
calrissian used to win the game of
sabacc and rebels
not so fast it appears i have an idiots
array
you could also hear a kid playing this
same hand in solo
uses a treadwell droid to roast the
great dragon meat in the fire of a pod
racer engine
this is great it's a kind of nod to
galaxy's edge where a restaurant
roasts meat on a spit in the fire of an
engine and then billy says
i like it medium rare i'm not some
rhodian for crying out loud
apparently rodians like their meat
cooked well done though
i like to think pally could be making
fun of greedo the rhodian whom han solo
famously faced off with in the same
cantina booth pelly was just sitting in
where
han solo cooked that rhodian well done
the frog woman is physically played by
actor misty rosas who also performed the
movements for kuwill and this character
wants
passage she needs her eggs fertilized by
the equinox or her line will end
she said her husband has settled on the
estuary moon of trask
in the system of the gas giant collide
ah we saw this gas giant in the trailer
as the battered razor crest drifts past
it so
trask must be the name of the water
planet but baby yoda clocks the
eggs right away i love how you can see
him waddling in right after them onto
the ship in the background
i suspect his desire for the eggs could
be more than just hunger
because when he presses his adorable
little face against that tank
you can see the eggs suddenly moving
closer to
him also notice that every time baby
yoda slurps an egg he does it in one
gulp
there's no chewing there so is baby yoda
eating these
ingesting and digesting or is he like
devouring them for safe keeping the way
i devour reese's cups for
shave keeping i'm just saying if the
others in the tank get lost or harmed or
if this frog woman ain't what she says
she is
baby yoda could end up hocking one of
these up and that line could live
on as a lover of the music on the show i
gotta shout out gearington's new baby
yoda theme those bell chimes are dreamy
innocent john williamsey it's just hard
not to see this chow down as something
pure and altruistic now the orabesh on
mando's navigation screen reads incoming
calm
and proximity alert with two new
republic x-wings piloted by
captain carson teva played by paul
sun-hyung lee
and the returning trapper wolf dave
baloney cameo and returning from episode
six last season that's why he recognizes
the razor crest from the incident at
boston 5. commando tries to wave them
off
may the force be with you and also with
you now of course manu doesn't really
know what the force is he doesn't really
know the jedi religion but presumably
this is just a new republic salutation
now that he has memorized to get out of
situations just like this one
but as they chase him down to the ice
planet carson's display has the same
two-dimensional graphics that luke had
and his cockpit in the trench run a new
hope like to see that continuity nice
but the production design adds some
really cool details to emphasize how
frigid this ice planet is notice the
frost covered edges of mando's helmet
and armor that increase and increases
the episode goes on and the way his
gauntlet
sticks frozen to his dashboard frog
woman hotwires the droid
zero from the bottom five episode
bringing back the voice of comedic actor
richard valuati
my husband has risked his life to carve
out existence for us
and as mando helps the frog woman scoop
her eggs out of the hot spring baby yoda
wanders over to some different eggs this
scene imagery very much inspired by the
moment kane an
alien came across the facehugger eggs as
well as the big ol egg patch laid by the
xenomorph queen that ripley finds in
aliens
now these spiders at first glance do
evoke the krikna of rebels but
they're actually an original trilogy
callback the knobby white spiders that
the krykna were based on
the older spider being an original
design by ralph mcquarrie for dagobah
and empire strikes back
later rendering done in 1993 and then
when they get back to the cockpit the
nav display now reads
maldo crease and ignition offline guys
maldocrease is the name of the ice
planet where mando found the mithral in
the very first scene of the series
that could mean this planet is
maldocrease maybe a different more
rugged part of it or it's just a new
destination popping up on the screen and
mando could be returning that planet in
the future
we did see in the trailer that horatio
sans blue mithral is returning later
this season so we could find out why he
was on that planet to begin with then
the mama spider is blasted away by the
two x-wing pilots who command mando for
his good deeds toward the new republic
security records also show that you put
your own life in harm's way to try to
protect that of lieutenant davin from
the new republic correctional corps
davin was the officer played by matt
lanter who voiced anakin in clone wars
and the last couple details
the markings of wolf's x-wing some
painted ties for
presumably each one he shot down i count
seven at least which more than five
would make him an ace
also the orbish over there translates to
rescue meaning these pilots might be
part of the new republic's search and
rescue corps
kind of like their coast guard now again
check out newrockstarsmerch.com
to get our this is away shirt and other
great options subscribe to
rockstars follow me at eavos follow me
rockstar see you next time i
have spoken
[Music]
you